je reçois maintenant roger planchon pour
le triomphe de l'amour au théâtre de
l'odéon quarante ans après la seconde
surprise de l'amour planchon planches à
nouveau sur marivaux dans une mise en
scène qui marie libertinage et amour
courtois mais n'épouse pas le
marivaudage bref planches on ne badine
pas avec l'amour bonsoir
donc vous êtes auteur vous êtes acteur
metteur en scène et cinéaste et finir un
film j'espère qu'on aura le temps d'en
parler et donc là on vous reçoit pour le
triomphe de l'amour donc à l'audience
jusqu'au 26 avril qui était monté à
villeurbanne et puis après vous avez
fait votre sinon qu lautrec et puis là
maintenant vous le donner à l'odéon et
pendant ce temps là où je posais la
question tout à l'heure c'est que
pendant ce temps il ya malgré tout un
spectacle à villeurbanne prix toujours
toujours d'accord je veux demander ce
qui se passait à villeurbanne alors on
l'a dit en commençant c'est un donjon
non seulement c'est le premier donjon
féminin en plus violemment féministe nom
vient d'avoir fait minispace quand même
à marivaux est avocat il connaît très
bien la situation des bonnes femmes qui
quand elle tombe amoureuse et qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'argent mais si elle se marie
c'est un valeur puisqu'elle donne tout
et s'enfermer dans un placard il ya
encore il ya encore des millions de
femmes peut-être même des billards sur
cette terre que dès ce soir là alors
l'histoire bon ça se passe dans en grèce
1 en grèce antique alors il ya dix
huitième oui quand même oui enfin le
lieu de dresde une espèce de graisse
revu et corrigé oui alors leonid qui est
jouée par isabelle gélinas l'excellente
isabelle gélinas donc elle est sur un l
et princesse elle s'aperçoit que le
trône a été en fait usurper par son
oncle et un jour elle découvre je le
fais vita comme ça elle découvre
l'héritier légitime et elle se déguise
en homme elle devient fonctions pour se
rapprocher de l'héritier légitime qui et
agissent et agissent et réfugié chez un
philosophe s'appelle armes aux 4 qui
jouait par vous on y reviendra et qui a
une soeur léontine les séduit tous les
deux fois la preuve on va arrêter de
rire tout le monde elle sait tout le
monde voilà c'est un peu comme dans le
bouquin de tina dont on va parler demain
faire à côté de théorèmes un peu ça
c'est à dire un peu film de pasolini il
ya 200 ans oui je sens oui c'est ça
c'est très crus en même temps oui alors
d'un côté il ya le libertinage le le
plus le plus total quoi le libertinage
qui a inspiré sa de la clau il était
très bon lecteur de marivaux oui ces
tarifs ont été traduits tous ses
contemporains mais vous savez le livre
est donc ils ont pris dans marivaux
l'essentiel de leurs bouilles oui et
vous dit enfin que cette tradition
libertines va jusqu'à roger vailland
aragon solaire c'est que finalement
c'est le sida qu'il ya un peu ça calme
un peu les ardeurs est calme les ardeurs
et d'un autre côté on va repartir oui de
l'autre côté il ya l'amour fou l'amour
absolu qui était un petit peu ça ça n'a
aucun rapport avec le 18e c'est à dire
que maryvonne une façon folle dans la
même pièce mais l'amour courtois
chevaleresque au sens où dante et ouais
pouvait aimer mais les deux alors passé
le thème c'est l'amour en l'amour
passion l'amour raison l'amont les
gradins donc ça intéresse tout le monde
en fait tout le monde
je continue de dire par là mais voilà si
je pars cruel si l'histoire très mais
tout le monde peut se retrouver là
dedans quoi je veux dire c'est déjà en
rit du début à la voilà elle est très
cruel mais puis c'est bourré en plus
alors marivaux a été le premier à parler
de tout ça d'une certaine façon parce
que bon c'est tellement c'est un sacré
mais ce qui est curieux c'est que les
contemporains ne le voit pas venir les
voltaire pense qu'il est lui l'héritier
de racine alors que ipic que le côté
pompe des tragédies et c'est évidemment
marivaux qui sait lire racines et qu'il
vénère la pièce est assez est assez dure
comme vous dites là étaient les racines
yann on pourrait dire d'une certaine
façon et ça c'est quelque chose que vous
alors roger planchon vous avez mis en
exergue quand vous aviez monté il ya 40
ans la seconde surprise de l'amour c'est
payerne ancien pdg a juste après
jurassic park voilà
il y avait une polémique parce que vous
aviez monter ça en refusant le en
refusant dix ans le badinage et en
mettant l'accent sur le manche on sait
s'il y avait une polémique à ce moment
là parce que les gens voyaient maryse
avait fait un énorme scandale fait un
énorme scandale à l'époque tout
simplement parce que j'avais fait une
chose très simple si vous les dents de
marivaux les personnages manquent tout
le temps punique mans c'est des espèces
des preuves qui font passer à celui qui
est en face donc pour la première fois
il y avait des très bon menteur qui
parlait avec un fond de vérité c'était
pas des menteurs maladroit c'était des
vrais menteur et on a alors brusquement
la cruauté de la pièce remonte voilà on
a compris à ce moment là qu'en fait
fallait pas confondre marivaux et
marivaudages c'est que c'est ce que vous
avez et en valeur parce que marivaux il
ya la trahison et la tromperie la
manipulation enfin comment dix essais
c'est dur
vous aimez pas quand on quand on montre
vous dites mois suivant on croit que
plus on monte des sentiments dégueulasse
plus on s'approche de la vérité est en
fait vous avez vous êtes vous êtes
disons un fidèle à marivaux qu'ensuite
il faut être un peu trop bon pour les
tracés quoi oui j'aime les auteurs qui
sont plutôt bons ouais je trouve qu'il
ya trop de complaisance actuellement sur
le discours cynique
il y avait avant des films y avait avant
des bouquins on disait tout le monde
était bon tout le monde est gentil et
maintenant c'est presque le contraire
est ce que c'est dégueulasse voilà plus
on approche de la vérité c'est pas vrai
oui on approche soit plus de la vérité
avec les deux glaces que c'est une idée
neuve alors le casting bon ben on l'a
dit jean et isabelle gélinas bien sûr il
ya il ya un groupe de jeunes acteurs
formidables
il ya régis royer qui joue dans le film
l'autre est qu'il y a micha lescot qui
est d'un grand acteur de 23 ans et vous
verrez que c'est un très grand acteur il
y à alain payen et il y a nathalie
krepski à vous alors vous vous dites je
suis un peu le bouche-trou de ma troupe
quoi c'est à dire là vous allez demander
à sami frey type ayant interdit aux
personnes étaient libres vous êtes
collecte ces savoirs exemple vous aviez
déjà remplacé tout le brasseur dans
georges dandin non plus un jour il se
foulent le pied alors je le remplace
c'est vraiment du talent alors votre vie
c'est très étonnant parce qu'en fait
vous vous dites volontiers quand vous
étiez petit votre père y poser des rails
de tramway et votre mère albeau sécher
un charcutier vous gardiez les vaches et
vous étiez dans le maquillage de l'âge
de 12 ans non mais ça me paraît plus à
une époque mais oui m'enfin vous étiez
gamin faisait quand même eu la croix
vous avez quand même la croix de guerre
à 12 ans et demi je dire tu es à
l'époque où on voit plutôt du pape ont
depuis six mois mais contre 32 tirs et
saint chély la croix de guerre pour
faits de résistance quand même bon ça
fait ça fait plaisir non ce que je veux
dire c'est comment vous avez la
révélation en fait du du spectacle ces
fonds peut raconter l'histoire parce
qu'elle est belle vous étiez chez les
pères allez vous faisiez le mur sont
allés voir tienne qu'on appelait les
frères à quatre bras parce qu'ils
avaient des branches bizarre il n'en
finit pas donc oui j'étais je n'allais
pas à l'école je suis jamais l'école et
je faisais le mur tous les jours et un
jour
surveillant un type très bien m'a pris à
la fin du 10 août et est après midi
gymnastique non c'était au cinéma qu'est
ce que tu as vu donne le film il dit
écoute tu as très mauvais goût il faut
que tu ailles voir il ya un très bon
film citizen kane et c'est vrai je l' ai
tellement raconté c'est vrai qu'il a
changé ma vie mais bien sûr c'est très
important on vous l'avait vu comme cette
fois un citizen kane 7/7 jours de suite
oui c'est toujours d'acier jusqu'au
début vous étiez jeune vous étiez pas
facile mais je venais quand même le
metteur en scène cowboys ben ouais c'est
ça regardez les vastes non mais c'est
fou dont vous l'avez vu cette fois puis
après vous ai dit je vais rentrer dans
le spectacle c'est quand même insensé
c'est le une sorte de chemin de damas
qui vous est titularisé se ressemblent
et vous vous lanciez d'entre eux d'aller
vous devenez j'ai même fait du théâtre
parce que wells avait une troupe de
théâtre oui oui qu'est
cette venue au théâtre par le cinéma
quand même un ski quand même quand même
pas en général c'est souvent la verte
vous dites souvent aussi jeté un petit
voyou j'ai été sauvé par le cinéma petit
voyou pourquoi beau
nom mais on avait des mauvaises
fréquentations
marais dieu dit des choses club service
j'ai tout à fait actuellement à
châteauroux vous avez vous êtes sauvés
de ça et vous avez rencontré artaud et
vous en êtes
oui enfin je suis passé directement de
du fond de l'ardèche si vous voulez un
milieu intellectuel paris où il y avait
à damas il ya vait marthe robert y avait
des gens comme ça et tous les amis
d'artaud oui donc c'était un milieu tout
à fait le contraire de ce que je
connaissais c'était l'époque des temps
modernes qui faisait beaucoup fréquenté
à l'époque sa retraite tout ça c'est
quand même incroyable comme aimerait
comme destin et après alors bon c'est la
carrière va pas faire tout votre
carrière parce que sinon ils seront
gérés tellement de choses c'est vrai
qu'à un moment vous avez pris le maquis
si vous êtes parti à villeurbanne pas
c'est une autre façon j'ai toujours été
j'ai toujours été attaché à deux choses
j'ai toujours été partisan de la
décentralisation donc j'ai jamais quitté
en vérité j'ai jamais bougé on m'a
proposé plusieurs fois la
comédie-française l'odéon chaillot et
c'est dans la ville et j'ai toujours dit
non non je suis attaché à ce cas comme
saine qui lui robert hossein qui vit
vraiment parti à reims où souhaitent y
rester dans le quartier latin mois à 11
ans j'étais amoureux d'une petite
danseuse du théâtre de villeurbanne j'y
suis resté
dites moi alors c'était charles hernu le
maire de villeurbanne vous étiez au
courant vous de ces histoires là qu'il
était un peu mais vous êtes vous
connaissez la jolie histoire de remuer
peut-être qu'elle va vous amuser le jour
il ya quinze jours trois semaines avant
que les histoires commencent je fais une
espèce de présentation dans une pièce de
shakespeare est en eux étaient là ils
étaient venus voir la présentation était
c'est sympa et je parle de shakespeare
et du pouvoir comme ça et puis arrive
toutes les histoires que vous connaissez
le jour où il est viré il quitte le
gouvernement et il vient seul le soir au
théâtre j'y suis à peu près seul ce soir
là il dit il faudrait que vous me
parliez un tout petit peu de shakespeare
et du pouvoir qu'est-ce qui raccorde
exactement l'histoire est vraie vraie
pro force et ça va pas changer vos
relations avec lui on n'allait pas vous
en doutiez pas là dans toutes les années
c'est parce que je savais alors il ya
une chose comme qui vous a un peu déçu
ce tir que bon le tnp sévir théâtre
national populaire est en fête dont
populaire certes mais que malgré tout il
ya un plafond vous dire qu'on peut pas
il ya des gens qui vont au théâtre ya
beaucoup de gens qui vont dans d'autres
théâtres mais que malgré tout le théâtre
peut pas être aussi populaire qu'on
l'entendait disons le sans n'y a même
plus le cinéma n'est même plus
maintenant c'est la télé
populaire ça bouge le théâtre a été
populaire après ça a été le cinéma et
maintenant c'est raté et peut-être
demain c'est autre chose alors vous êtes
engagé totalement dans le théâtre
puisque vous prenez jamais de vacances
il ya une anecdote qui célèbre sur vous
c'est que le jour de votre mariage vous
avez retardé la répétition d'une heure
pour vous marier c'est tout est fait
comme ça c'est comme ça ouais j'ai
jamais été autrement des pères de
famille en plus parce que ça oui
oui oui je sais ça vous les prenez
jeunes par les pratiques des 24 ans
taylor alors vous avez dit les grands
théâtres doivent prendre en main leur
destin leur destin audiovisuelle je
pense qu'il faut que le théâtre se
transforme enfin lancer dans la bataille
quand tu veux qu'on essaye de mener si
vous voulez je pense que quelques grands
et il faudrait changer un peu les choses
dans le théâtre moi je pense que il
devrait exister des centres de création
des véritables centres de création qui
face à la fois du spectacle vivant et
des spectacles audiovisuels que ce
soient des films ou des télés et puis
cette dichotomie un oui parce que tous
les acteurs le souhaite en réalité c'est
très curieux je suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs à le dire simplement
évidemment une idée comme ça ça marche
quand il y à un politique important qui
dit on peut peut-être essayer ça
faudrait andré malraux pour faire ça il
faudrait un jeu la fois jacques la
grande époque non j'ai pas des fois
quelqu'un peuvent faire aussi pour vous
le souhaite alors vous avez donc
évidemment vous êtes acteur et vous êtes
réalisateur s'est réalisé
jusqu'aujourd'hui trois films khwaja
dandin pas georges dandin dandin louis
enfant roi et lautrec alors qu'il sort
en septembre cette percée pourrait alors
oui oui avec non mais vraiment parce que
l'art vous ça doit être qu'est-ce que
pourquoi de poubelles lautrec je veux
dire pourquoi que qu'elle dix minutes
avant de choisir lautrec jeu seulement
d'accord mais bon j'ai toujours admiré
ce peintre et
bastien précisément c'est un homme bon
qui a un humour fabuleux mais c'est un
jeune type lautrec c'est quelqu'un qui
meurt à l'âge de mozart et les gens ne
savent pas très bien où ça oui c'est
vrai le village une espèce de légende
autour de lui donc c'était amusant de
faire un film là-dessus donc je vais
arrêter le avec la même troupe des faits
l'autre côté maintenant il ils font
marivaux alors vous vous êtes
autodidacte et vous vous êtes énormément
intéressé à l'histoire êtes de vraiment
quelque chose qui vous a ébloui et
habité et vous dites le 20e siècle est
une catastrophe ambiante parce que
finalement eagle s'adonner l'état
prussien nietzsche le nazisme enfin
jusqu'à turin et marx le stalinisme ou
les regards des siècles non je pense
très barbare mais on va maintenant tout
le monde le dit ouais tout le monde l'a
dit et même l'intégrisme par dessus en
constante en pillant est ce que vous
pensez pas que c'est parce que c'est le
premier siècle de l'homme sans dieu non
c'est vrai ça fait vieux s'étant
éloignés comme dirait l'autre et ben oui
ça provoque quelque chose en gros si
vous voulez d'ailleurs on va le cynisme
d'hitler a gagné à peu près dans les
têtes ouais c'est en gros ce qui vous
fait le plus peur maintenant c'est le
signe finalement ce que vous disiez sur
le oui je pense que je pense que c'est
payant quand les gens disent y'a trop de
violence au cinéma je dis c'est pas les
coups de pistolet parce que les gamins
ils savent très bien que c'est de la
chorégraphie oui la fin c'est comme une
danse mais tandis que ce qui est diffusé
dans les têtes par les dialogues
commencer autre chose ça va directement
dans directement directement dans la
tête il servait dans la tête et après on
se ressert quoi bon choix et c'est fini
c'est vrai ça passe vite un quart
d'heure je suis désolé et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu